Phillip Schofield has left this morning
[Music]
with his young boys he's got daughters
fit camera is gay in 2020 which is
wonderful as we all know there's nothing
more Progressive than banging a load of
young boys behind your wife's back
especially if they're young enough to be
your grandchild I'm surprised he wasn't
sponsored by Bud Light
if he was banging 19 year old girls he'd
be fired and destroyed on social media
but since he was shagging young Lads
that makes him itv's answer to Martin
Luther King now he's been fired after a
rift with Holly Willoughby and
apparently she's annoyed because he
didn't tell her that his brother is a
convicted nonce but can you really trust
someone who spent the 80s with their
hands shoved up at gopher's backside
no wonder he's a wrong